[Applaudissements]
sciences bonjour et bienvenue pour ce
faux raccords anatomiques en compagnie
de michel bonjour michel mangeront
michel balle est folle elle m'appelle
michel alors je l'appelle michel aussi
on s'appelle tous michel voilà un animal
sur le mauvais continent des crânes qui
n'ont rien à faire là des vessies qu'on
veut nous faire passer pour des
lanternes
rien ne m'échappe évidemment spoiler
alert est il utile de le préciser
le cinéma c'est l'art de tromper son
monde dans la joie et la bonne humeur
quoi de plus satisfaisant qu'un effet
réussi comme ce requin tigre bien
reconnaissable à ses dents correctement
identifiés par les protagonistes des
dents de la mer comme n'étant pas le
requin blanc qu'il cherche
mais comme le bouleau d'hollywood c'est
de nous raconter de belles histoires ça
ne se passe pas toujours comme ça tu es
et puisqu'on parle de requins à vous
connaissez certainement le megalodon le
terrible requin géant préhistorique du
film en eaux troubles mais vous
connaissez certainement beaucoup moins
le gentil megalodon celui qui a mordu la
poussière et dont les dents sont
fièrement exposée comme trophée dans des
dessins animés pourtant tout mignon le
voici dans hôtel transylvania 3 qui fait
la déco sur la terrasse d'un bar et on
voit là une dent dans vaiana qui sert de
perles au collier de maui c'est
peut-être à sac il sert son gros
hameçons à pêcher megalodon ah bah merci
disney de ruiner nos rêves nature en
parlant de menace pas très menaçante
vous avez été nombreux après le dernier
faux raccords anatomique à nous demander
de parler du crâne d'alien dans le film
predator 2 alors après avoir brisé le
mythe d'un predator un nous allons
aujourd'hui tirer sur l'ambulance avec
predator 2 car en effet ceci n'est pas
un crâne d'alien mais mais qu'est ce que
voulait dire michel ce crâne pourtant
bien la forme d'un crâne d'alien oui
michel mais rappelez vous que les aliens
sont inspirés des arthropodes des petits
êtres dotés d'un exosquelette comme les
insectes et les arachnides ah oui c'est
vrai que leur société est calquée sur
celle des fourmis avec une reine bon 2
qu'il a une bouche en forme de piston
comme les larves de libellules et que
leur design cauchemardesque est
directement inspiré du corps délit mule
c'est ça et on voit bien l'exosquelette
chez les lits mule c'est un squelette
externe pas interne
oui ça je le vois bien m'aimer où voulez
vous en venir michel c'est simple si les
alliés ont un squelette externe ils ont
pas de squelettes interne ça veut dire
pas d'os pas de colonne vertébrale et
pas de crâne ou alors ça and aliens qui
ressemblait à ça c'est du pipeau ce
crâne c'est un faux le predator est venu
se la péter quoi mais c'est pas possible
à vous allez pas pourrir la saga
predator deux fois quand même jeu
la preuve que c'est du flan ça c'est un
trou pour light a déjà vu des yeux sur
un alien toi bon bah il va bien falloir
se rendre à l'évidence le predator c'est
juste de la poudre aux yeux
un escroc oui tant qu'à parler de faux
crâne michel a bien remarqué le logo
turati quoi ouais ben c'est le crâne
d'un tyrannosaure et alors oui vous
choque pas ce crâne non il a quoi ce
crâne et à panarine ce crâne hamas c'est
vrai elles sont où les narines
et puis si c'est un crâne de t-rex il
lui manque aussi les fausses temporal je
savais bien que mélanger leur adn avec
celui des grenouilles ça donnerait des
résultats chelou mais revenons à nos
moutons nous parlions d'alien alors
intéressons nous au dernier opus de la
saga alien covenante bon là michel ça
suffit ça fait deux fois qu'on tire sur
l'ambulance la wii mais c'est tellement
drôle
aline covenante je disais qu'ils nous
initie au concept de biodiversité disney
la biodiversité disney c'est quand vous
entendez les gens vous dire moi j'aime
trop les animaux ce sont des êtres
sensibles et intelligents mais qu'ils
oublient un peu vite que les araignées
les méduses sont aussi des animaux en
bref c'est réduire la biodiversité
animale au seul mammifère est encore
simplement à ceux qui nous intéressent
typiquement une dynastie de basse cour
avec au premier rang les chiens et chats
et les chevaux parce que les pangolins
tout le monde s'en fout donc aline
covenante est atteint du syndrome de la
biodiversité disney quand on lui demande
de nous montrer biodiversité
extraterrestre à la place il nous montre
sa un simple coquillages terrestre de la
famille des murex un scarabée on ne peut
plus de chez nous et ces crânes là en
fond on reconnaît l'arrière crâne d'un
cochon domestique d'un cheval d'une
girafe et d'un chameau bon on leur
accordera bien michel que la girafe et
le chameau ça fait plus le roi lion
queue basse cour ouais enfin c'est
m'explique toujours pas comment le
prometheus à embarquer une girafe à bord
en fait la planète des ingénieurs si ça
se trouve c'est la terre depuis le début
[Musique]
dit michel en parlant de royan vous
aviez remarqué l'animal qui n'a rien à
faire là dans le roi lion oh là je sens
que vous allez nous sortira de ces
obscurs truc du genre l'un des vers de
terre que mange timon et pumbaa c'est en
fait une espèce très rare de coléoptères
qu'on rencontre en asie du sud-est et
ingénieurs pas du tout c'est bien plus
gros que ça à regarder
et bah quoi vous ne voyez pas là le
tamanoir ya un tamanoir un fourmilier
d'amérique du sud en afrique
c'est peut-être un fourmilier d'afrique
sûrement pas regardez voici les deux
espèces de fourmi les africains ça c'est
un oryctérope et ça c'est un pangolin ah
oui le premier n'a pas ce joli collier
de poils foncés est le deuxième a
carrément des écailles à la place des
poils 1 à voir avec tam et noir vous
voulez dire qu on nous a caché la vérité
mais si on ne peut même plus faire
confiance au roi lion majesté tu agis
stan colossal content super action
il est baleines les gens se foutent des
baleines ah bah non
michel sas est plus gros a parce que
dans l'hilarante scène du mariage de
jack sparrow dans pirates des caraïbes
la revanche de salazar la cérémonie a
lieu dans le cadavre d'une baleine
en effet c'est vrai mais en même temps
ça crève les yeux c'est pas comme si
c'était un exploit d'avoir repéré sa et
ben s'ils crèvent les miens c'est que
cette baleine montre que pirates des
caraïbes n'a pas du tout lieu dans les
caraïbes quoi mais qu'est ce que vous
racontez michel c'est simple vous voyez
le crâne de cette baleine le museau et
fin il n'est pas plat comme celui des
autres baleines qu'on appelle rorqual
comme la baleine bleue ce museau fin est
typique des baleines franches maintenant
soyez un bon pirate et regarder
attentivement cette carte moussaillons
haut mais oui voici la répartition
totale des trois espèces de baleines
franches dans le monde
et voici la mer des caraïbes et on voit
très bien que les deux ne se chevauchent
pas il n'y a donc pas moyen qu'un
cadavre de baleine franche se retrouve
échouée dans les caraïbes c'est du
pipeau tout ça ah oui michel mais là je
tiens un article qui aimait la théorie
qu'en fait ce squelette c'est celui du
kraken le kraken oui bah oui le creca ni
z sur michel pas ce que tu dis n'a aucun
sens bah oui c'est ce qu'ils disent dans
l'article kraken parce que les du kraken
un mollusque céphalopode baba pas
pourquoi pas je vois pas pourquoi les
squelettes
non mais attendez michel je voulais
c'est une minute pour réfléchir à la
notion de squelettes de mollusques
mais même elle je lui si mais si allez
voir sur wikipédia c'est mon michel vous
avez fait le deuil de votre théorie de
fans moisi les mots me manquent
c'est sûr que pirate de l'atlantique
nord ça fait pas rêver au maintien
cet extrait de star wars est forte à
propos puisque star wars 8 le dernier
jada il nous apprend une chose capitale
on peut chercher des fossiles grâce à la
force ab oui regardez ray en train de se
concentrer et pouf le petit fossiles qu
un paléontologue locale n'a jamais vu
voilà qui va simplifier considérablement
la recherche du chaînon manquant
en parlant de morceaux manquants vous
aviez remarqué que les gens dans
terminator ont la fâcheuse tendance à
avoir beaucoup de têtes mais pas
beaucoup de squelette
ah c'est vrai ça michel je vais vous
donner perspicaces mais bon quand on y
réfléchit les crânes ça fait peur alors
que les omoplates et les côtes bon et
puis comme les crânes ça fait vachement
peur est bon aux normes et à mais c'est
rachel dans blade runner 2049 michel que
pouvez vous nous dire à propos du
squelette de rachel mais qui sert pas de
rachel la femme ne réplicante du premier
film il retrouve son squelette dans le
deuxième je vois pas bah ça squelette la
princesse qu'elle est là mais c'est pas
du tout celui de rachel
quoi quoi quoi ah ah non mais ça suffit
à vous vous allez pas aussi massacré ce
chef-d'oeuvre du cinéma chef-d'oeuvre
une purge
oui quel ennui ah bah ça c'est vos goûts
michel à soyez objectifs un peu ce film
est bon je vais être objectif ce film
était long et puis pour ce qui est du
squelette il n'est objectivement pas
celui de rachel il n'y a aucun doute là
dessus
regardez les radiographies du crâne
normalement les dents devrait apparaître
en blanc brillant au lieu de ça on ne
voit rien d'autre qu'une mâchoire
édentée rongé par l'âge comme celle
d'une personne âgée
rachel est censé être morte en couches
donc elle est forcément morte avant la
ménopause ce cadavre est celui d'une
personne morte de vieillesse pas celui
de rachel cqfd
j'admets que la comparaison semble
marcher mais vous oubliez un détail les
dents sont à part de la mâchoire elles
sont tombés pendant la décomposition du
corps ce cadavre possède bien des dents
on les voit ici
arrêt à je vous ai bien eus je vous ai
piégée échec et mat michel vous avez
échoué au aaa les cas d'accord jamais
mais des fêtes
vous admettez votre défaite oui j'admets
défaite
j'admets défaite mais dans ce cas
michèle vous allez pouvoir m'expliquer
pourquoi le crâne de rachel possède des
caractéristiques typiquement masculines
comme des angles de la mâchoire aussi
prononcer un menton proéminent écarts et
des processus master gigantesque ou bien
cette bosse la suture du frontal à
dépareiller taux bas jeu à et puis
cerise sur le gâteau va falloir
m'expliquer pourquoi ce crâne ne
ressemble pas du tout au crâne de
l'actrice qui joue rachel et qui a été
scanné pour l'occasion donc merci pour
le coup des dents mais ce que l'état
n'est pas celui d'une femme morte en âge
de procréer c'est celui d'un homme âgé
je crois qu'il va falloir qu'on se mette
d'accord sur le fait de pas être
d'accord sur ce coup là michel faites ce
que vous voulez michel mais moi au moins
mon interprétation est cohérente avec le
film parce que tout le monde sait que la
vraie rachel elle elle avait les yeux
verts enfin terminons par l'un des plus
grands et des plus persistants mythe à
propos des dinosaures celui disant
qu'ils étaient tellement gros qu'ils
avaient besoin d'un deuxième cerveau
dans l'arrière train
et quel autre film aurait pu tomber dans
ce panneau monumentale que celui où on
entend la phrase désormais devenue culte
c'est que tous les yaggeurs son
numérique
non on sera tous nucléaire du nucléaire
analogique analogique et oui jamie
analogique contraction habile des mots
annales et logique le tout signifiant
que la logique on languit pacific rim
donc ce film qui nous explique que les
caïds juste sont tellement énormes
qu'ils ont besoin d'un second cerveau
comme les dinosaures
nous savons tous les deux que les caïds
joue son si grand qu'ils leur faut deux
cerveaux pour bouger comme les
dinosaures alors correction dans
l'univers du film les dinosaures étaient
des cailloux ils le disent là les
cailloux sont déjà tenues sur la terre
pour faire un essai c'étaient les
dinosaures sa mère lipopette ce film est
plus gratiné qu'un plat de lasagnes
mais revenons à nos moutons michel
l'idée que les dinosaures avaient un
second sa re nous vient tout droit du
19e siècle
c'est donc du bon gros reliquat de la
paléontologie à papy howie mon petit
michel et elle m'appelle mon petit
michel maintenant est bas vivement que
ça se termine cette vidéo elle vient
d'un moulage de la cavité pelvienne de
stieg aux russes qui avaient fait le
célèbre le redoute et l'impitoyable
othniel charles marsh n'ont cherché par
richard dow n a rien à voir là dedans ou
tenu à charm marche donc qui en 1881 me
fais un moulage de la qualité du bassin
contenant la moelle épinière d'un
stégosaure et qui en ôta le volume
incroyable et je parie qu'il ne lui a
pas fallu longtemps pour conclure que le
bassin contenait un deuxième cerveau
pour lui commander l'arrière train c'est
tout à fait ça
mais ne connaissant anatomiques modernes
montre que tous les animaux terrestres
ont une cavité dans le bassin qui est dû
au simple fait que tous les nerfs des
jambes convergent vers la moelle
épinière à cet endroit
rien à voir avec un deuxième cerveau
donc rien avoir du tout en effet preuve
en est que les baleines qui sont les
plus gros animaux vivants qui ait jamais
existé ne possède pas de cavités dans
les vertèbres de la région du bassin
simplement parce qu'elles n'ont pas de
jambes pas de jambes paciocco enfin je
veux dire pas de convergence des nerfs
donc pas besoin de leur faire de la
place
et pourtant les baleines en aux besoins
de coordination dans la r train pour
nager correctement mais le cerveau à lui
seul suffit pas besoin de cerveaux
secondaire et c'était pareil pour les
dinosaures c'est deuxième fois encore un
atomique est terminé merci de l'avoir
suivi n'oubliez pas d'aller jeter un
coup d'oeil aux premiers si cela n'est
pas déjà fait quant à moi je vous dis
est la semaine prochaine michel et cette
fois j'aurai du lourd du très très lourd
oui oui c'est ça mimiche la semaine
prochaine du très très lourd les a
[Musique]